Oh
[Music]
hi and welcome to this week's episode of
the lab where we take your questions and
turn them into experiments I'm Greg and
I'm Mitch and this week we're talking
about all different types of disgust do
you find anything in particular
disgusting when you're on the subway
people are using your face and spiders
Oh interesting you bring that up because
today we're actually going to be forcing
ourselves to interact with a tarantula
which we both find incredibly gross
we're gonna potentially be drinking our
own pee so you know and then after that
we're gonna make ourselves eat a bunch
of concoctions that are pretty nasty
okay I realize like we actually like we
need to open it for people to see you
but like I'm so gross okay so the actual
look of disgust when you actually you
know have your brows furrowed your lips
raised your nose kind of clenched up is
a universal symbol for disgust and it's
actually created it throughout evolution
so that we can warn other people that
the thing that we are doing could
potentially be harmful to ourselves okay
spider if somebody vomits it's a huge
sign that they've not only it's
disgusting first of all and it's also a
sign that's something they've ingested
is potentially poisonous or have made
them else that you shouldn't be eating
that because it's disgusting oh my god
oh my god okay great
no don't bigger closer to us what do we
do though I don't want to touch it after
oh my god I don't know if I can do this
thank you for coming to you I don't know
I don't know I actually don't know what
to do right now should we just I don't
know who's gonna touch her when she gets
out
obviously when interacting with trans oh
we feel disgust I feel very hungry right
now but also we feel fear and it's
really interesting because both disgust
and fear are core emotions that are
built within us to protect us from
potential dangers so if I if I were to
type this this spider is an example of
sensory disgust when you think of
insects or mice or all different sorts
of things that kind of grows too so it's
often because they could be carriers of
disease something like a cockroach isn't
necessarily dangerous for you but it
could indicate that your home or the
space you're living in is actually
unclean and so we've had this
evolutionary reaction to find they're
disgusting to protect our own cells if
you sneeze on yourself or if your best
friend's sneeze is on you it's not
nearly as bad as if a stranger sneezes
on you on the subway and it's kind of
like
I don't see tarantulas often yeah I have
no spirit I'm known exactly you don't
know this spider if we knew her
personally maybe be a little less scared
I'm so sorry Susan Sarandon Molly oh
that's disgusting
so we wanted to test some things that we
perceive as disgusting like a toilet and
a urinal and then put them side by side
with the things we use on a regular
basis like our phones and the keyboards
on our laptops to see which is actually
more disgusting we then took the swab
samples from each location to an agar
petri dish and let the cultures grow
then we left them in a warm right place
and here are the results so the cleanest
and least bacteria grown was in the
toilet which is everybody okay the
journal and the phone were about the
same and the most disgusting place was
the keyboard that's all kind of
surprising considering these two things
are the things we touch every single day
basically and they're the most
disgusting now it's time to drink our
home pee and so to do that we have to
now go pee pee baggies oh my gosh so
it's pretty disgusting to drink your own
pee like this and but we are gonna test
is we're actually gonna be filtering our
pee using this lifesaver filter and see
if after filtering it and knowing that
all we're really drinking is water
installed are we still gonna be grossed
out by the fact that we have poured our
pee into this right device what's really
interesting about this is relates to
something called interpersonal disgust
which is that I'm gonna find it much
easier to drink my own pee even though
it's being cleaned equally as yours than
yours I do not want to drink yeah I
think that's not way nastier I mean like
I don't really want to drink my pee but
I don't want to drink yours even more
you know it smells like cardboard I like
the smell of my own farts like I can
wipe my own butt but as soon as it's
like someone else's like dirty blight
but I'm like cute it's all because like
we need to be able to go after so
disgust is really fascinating and I'm
just gonna go yeah have you got to do it
fast otherwise you're gonna spill why is
that so disgusting like that doesn't
have thought of Eire a smells like plain
flake Oh
pissed oh oh it's not good it's not shot
holy clear but it is much more clear now
I don't know what annoy strong my hands
is be pleasant II yeah I think this is
your P it does look clear when you're
first everybody yours is clear no but I
think it's because you're this
completely clear yeah it's already
looking more yellow yeah yeah okay okay
okay I'm like gross like I'm kind of
like does it taste like my cereal
well it's P so we're like very aware but
if someone it's up like oh this is like
essence of cucumber or water I might be
like oh yeah you're right like kinda
gross tasting like I wouldn't choose it
but it's not like revolting which that
sip tasted revolting to me so it's
definitely a law in our heads a lot of
the times disgust can also be correlated
with food so today we're gonna start by
eating the three meals of the day
starting with breakfast there's nothing
quite like a yummy bowl of cereal with
some wholesome milk to go along with it
and your lovely OJ why is this
disgusting oh oh oh my god can you see
this it looks like egg we love when
things are pure so we want you know
organic kale juice we even would want to
drink orange juice when it's pure but as
soon as you mix it with milk all of a
sudden becomes disgusting little tiny
chunks it's like really gross so for
lunch I love a hot dog and all my hot
dog I enjoy some mustard and ketchup and
with my hot dog I love a glass of nice
colas fresh so what happens if you
eliminate the hot dog and with this Cola
we decide to add some condiments like a
must
[Music]
and so we're deception so weird because
like the muttering kind of are in class
so you kind of get some coke and you get
like clumpy ER and clumpy ER last but
not least you want a delicious dinner
here we have some broccoli some rice
some turkey but what happens if we blend
it's like like so rubbery oh my god I
don't like the noise either it's like
yeah you know that sounds like I mean
it's a strangely buttery and some people
are so scared to have this happen to
even have food touching on their plate
let alone mixed altogether it's kind of
weird that the word disgust is used for
what we did today but also in a lot of
other contexts right like when we're
disgusted at certain people or certain
acts
yeah like moral disgust and I think it's
interesting cuz this is sort of a
metaphor for purity like we like things
to be pure you know we will eat all of
these things on their own bassoons mix
them up they're gross and it's sort of
like there's other forms of moral
discussed for example fairness people
get disgusted and I am disgusted when
you think about really rich affluent
excessive wealth that exists and then
maybe they take advantage of people who
are impoverished or who need more to me
that is disgusting isn't weird that it's
the same emotion I feel when I eat like
blended food is it the same emotion
we're feeling for the food or is it two
different emotions that we just used the
same word for yeah and it's interesting
we were talking earlier about the fear
of the unknown and the disgust of the
unknown we found that tranch low so
disgusting because we haven't been
around
Angela's mom a lot and we're taught that
they are disgusting and it's interesting
because when you think about
homosexuality it's been places where
it's not accepted or maybe it's more
unknown that people think it's a
disgusting act and so ignorant is
actually very dangerous in those I think
so you can make a correlation there that
if you know if you if society changes
and homosexuality is accepted and
there's more exposure to it like hashtag
modern family then people start like oh
this isn't disgusting and you can like
progress in that way so it's like a
weird interesting correlation between
the biology of looking at a tranche
alone what we feel and then the actual
moral disgust that some people have
towards something like homosexuality on
a lighter note surveys have shown that
the most disgusting word in the English
language is moist and now it's time for
this week in science talk this week
diamond particles are being considered
to redirect the sun's energy and fight
climate change it's a desperate but
feasible geoengineering strategy that
involves throwing diamonds in the sky
scientists are using ultrasonic speakers
to levitate objects in three dimensions
with more control than ever before
so you can probably say goodbye to those
weird segways from 2015 and hello to the
hoverboards of the future and finally if
you're a teacher or student in Canada
and want Mitch Knotts may become a film
of video with you at your school or when
a bunch of other different Samsung
prizes we have a challenge for you go to
solve for tomorrow dossier to find out
all the details of how you can join in
this amazing experience that's our
update for the week you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter with our handles
here we love hearing all the news and
updates and science information that
you've given us this week be sure to
subscribe for more science and we'll see
you next Sunday for another episode of
the lab
[Music]
you